Solverul variațional cuantic pentru valori proprii, sau VQE, este unul dintre cei mai vechi algoritmi hibrizi cuantic-clasici și este
interesant din mai multe motive. În primul rând, după cum vom vedea în acest videoclip, este o abordare promițătoare pentru anumite tipuri de probleme. În al doilea rând, este important
din punct de vedere istoric și a deschis calea pentru mulți algoritmi îmbunătățiți, precum adapt VQE.
Și în final, VQE este destul de simplu. Este ușor de înțeles ce fac calculatoarele cuantice și clasice în acest algoritm
și cum interacționează. Există patru componente principale ale unui calcul VQE.
În primul rând, există un operator, adesea un Hamiltonian, pe care îl vom numi H, ce descrie o proprietate a sistemului pe care
dorești să o optimizezi. Un alt mod de a spune asta este că cauți vectorul propriu al acestui operator care
corespunde valorii proprii minime. Acel vector propriu îl numim adesea starea fundamentală.
Urmează un ansatz — cuvânt ce înseamnă aproximare. Acesta este un circuit cuantic care pregătește o stare cuantică ce aproximează
vectorul propriu căutat. De fapt, ansatz-ul este o familie de circuite cuantice, deoarece unele dintre gate-urile din
ansatz sunt parametrizate. Adică, primesc un parametru pe care îl putem varia. Această familie de circuite cuantice
poate pregăti o familie de stări cuantice ce aproximează starea fundamentală.
Apoi avem nevoie de un estimator, un mijloc de a estima valoarea de așteptare a operatorului H pentru starea cuantică variaţională curentă.
Uneori ceea ce ne interesează cu adevărat este tocmai această valoare de așteptare, pe care o
numim funcție de cost. Alteori ne interesează o funcție mai complicată care poate fi scrisă totuși plecând de la
una sau mai multe valori de așteptare.
În final, avem nevoie de un optimizator clasic, un algoritm care variază parametrii pentru a minimiza această funcție de cost.
Să conturăm problema pe care vrem să o rezolvăm și abordarea generală, înainte de a explica rolul calculului cuantic. Putem
formula multe probleme de optimizare esențiale în știință și industrie ca probleme de valori proprii pentru matrice. De obicei,
vrei valoarea proprie minimă a matricei tale și vectorul propriu corespunzător. Matricea H ar putea fi
un Hamiltonian ce descrie energia unui sistem fizic. Iar valoarea proprie minimă ar fi energia stării fundamentale
E0, iar vectorul propriu ar fi starea cuantică fundamentală corespunzătoare, notată adesea psi sub 0.
Sau matricea ar putea descrie o funcție de cost complicată asociată cu probleme de optimizare combinatorică,
cum ar fi în logistică, iar starea proprie s_subopt ar fi o soluție optimă a
problemei, de exemplu un șir binar ce etichetează o tăietură într-un graf al unei rețele de distribuție. În practică,
este obișnuit să se folosească termenul Hamiltonian pentru toate matricele de interes, chiar și în afara științelor fizice. Să zicem
că suntem interesați de o matrice cu n linii și n coloane. Astfel de probleme pot fi rezolvate rapid și exact folosind
solvere clasice pentru n de până la câteva sute sau mii, fără nicio presupunere despre matrice. Pentru matrice
rare, adică cele cu majoritatea intrărilor egale cu zero, n poate fi mult mai mare, chiar și un miliard, pe un laptop.
Dar pentru probleme cu adevărat enorme care depășesc aceste cifre, metodele aproximative sau euristice sunt adesea necesare.
Cu cât matricea este mai mare și mai puțin rară, cu atât problema este mai dificil de tratat și cu atât mai multe trucuri inteligente trebuie aplicate. Presupune că matricea ta este atât de
mare încât diagonalizarea exactă nu este o opțiune. Presupune în plus că știi suficient despre problema ta încât poți
face unele presupuneri despre structura generală a stării țintă și vrei să explorezi stări similare cu
estimarea ta inițială pentru a vedea dacă poți reduce mai mult costul sau energia. Aceasta este o abordare variaţională și este o metodă
care se folosește când diagonalizarea exactă nu este o opțiune pe un calculator clasic. Ar funcționa astfel:
Mai întâi, faci o stare de estimare cu niște parametri theta pe care îi vei varia.
Deși această estimare inițială ar putea fi aleatorie, nu este recomandat. Vrem să folosim cunoștințele despre problema în cauză
pentru a ne adapta estimarea cât mai mult posibil.
În al doilea rând, am calcula valoarea de așteptare a operatorului cu sistemul în acea stare.
În al treilea rând, am modifica parametrii variaționali și am repeta.
În al patrulea rând, am folosi informațiile acumulate despre peisajul stărilor posibile din subspațiul tău variațional pentru a face estimări din ce în ce mai bune și
a ne apropia de starea țintă.
Principiul variațional garantează că starea noastră variaţională nu poate produce o valoare proprie mai mică decât cea a
stării fundamentale țintă. Deci cu cât valoarea de așteptare este mai mică, cu atât aproximarea noastră a stării fundamentale este mai bună. Să
vorbim despre dificultatea fiecărui pas din această abordare.
Setarea sau actualizarea parametrilor este ușoară din punct de vedere computațional. Dificultatea constă în selectarea unor parametri inițiali utili,
motivați fizic. Folosirea informațiilor acumulate din iterațiile anterioare pentru a actualiza parametrii în așa fel
încât să te apropii de starea fundamentală este netrivială. Dar există algoritmi de optimizare clasici care fac
acest lucru destul de eficient. Această optimizare clasică este costisitoare doar pentru că poate necesita multe
iterații. În cel mai rău caz, numărul de iterații poate scala exponențial cu n.
Cel mai costisitor pas computațional individual este aproape sigur calculul valorii de așteptare a matricei tale folosind o
stare dată. Matricea de n ori n trebuie să acționeze asupra vectorului de n elemente, ceea ce corespunde la ordinul n pătrat
operații de înmulțire în cel mai rău caz. Aceasta trebuie făcută la fiecare iterație a parametrilor. Pentru matrice
extrem de mari, costul computațional este ridicat. Acum imaginează-ți că delegi această porțiune a
calculului unui calculator cuantic. În loc să calculezi această valoare de așteptare, o estimezi pregătind
starea s(theta) pe calculatorul cuantic folosind ansatz-ul tău variațional, apoi efectuând măsurători.
Să analizăm un pic. H nu este în general ușor de măsurat. De exemplu, ar putea fi alcătuit din mulți
operatori Pauli X, Y și Z care nu comutează.
Dar H poate fi scris ca o combinație liniară de termeni H_subalfa, fiecare dintre aceștia fiind ușor de măsurat. De exemplu,
operatori Pauli sau grupuri de operatori Pauli care comutează pe biți. Valoarea de
așteptare a lui H pentru starea S este suma ponderată a valorilor de așteptare ale termenilor constituenți H_alfa.
WEBVTT
Această expresie este valabilă pentru orice stare s, dar o vom folosi specific cu starea noastră variaţională s(theta).
Fiecare dintre termenii h_alfa poate fi măsurat de m ori, producând eșantioane de măsurare s_subalfa_j, cu j de la
1 la m, și returnează o valoare de așteptare și o abatere standard. Putem suma
acești termeni și propaga erorile prin sumă.
Aceasta nu necesită înmulțiri la scară mare și nici niciun proces care să scaleze neapărat ca n la pătrat. În schimb,
necesită mai multe măsurători pe calculatorul cuantic. Dacă nu ai nevoie de prea multe, această abordare ar putea fi
eficientă. Aceasta este partea cuantică a VQE. Dar să vorbim despre motivele pentru care s-ar putea să nu fie eficientă. Un motiv
pentru multe măsurători este reducerea incertitudinii statistice în estimările tale, pentru calcule de
mare precizie. Un alt motiv este numărul de șiruri Pauli necesare pentru a acoperi întreaga matrice. Deoarece matricele Pauli plus
identitatea acoperă spațiul tuturor operatorilor de o anumită dimensiune, avem garanția că
putem scrie matricea noastră de interes ca o sumă ponderată de operatori Pauli, așa cum am făcut înainte. Aici C_alfa este un
coeficient numeric, iar H_alfa este un șir de operatori Pauli acționând asupra tuturor qubit-urilor ce descriu sistemul tău.
H_alfa ar avea o formă ca aceasta, în care al n-lea operator Pauli de la dreapta acționează asupra celui de-al n-lea qubit. Deci putem
măsura operatorul nostru măsurând o serie de operatori Pauli. Dar nu putem măsura toți acei operatori Pauli
simultan. Operatorii Pauli, excluzând identitatea, nu comutează între ei dacă sunt
asociați cu același qubit. De exemplu, putem măsura I Z IIZ și ZZ
XZ simultan, deoarece putem măsura I și Z simultan pentru al treilea
qubit. Și putem cunoaște I și X simultan pentru primul qubit. Dar nu putem
măsura toți Z și ZZ ZX simultan, deoarece Z și X nu
comutează și ambii acționează asupra qubit-ului de indice zero.
Deci descompunem matricea H într-o sumă de Pauli care acționează asupra unor qubit-uri diferite.
Unii termeni din acea sumă pot fi măsurați toți odată. Numim asta un grup de Pauli care comutează. În funcție de
câți termeni care nu comutează există, s-ar putea să avem nevoie de multe astfel de grupuri. Notăm cu T numărul unor astfel de grupuri de Pauli care comutează.
Pauli care comutează.
Dacă T este mic, acest lucru ar putea funcționa bine.
Dacă h are milioane de grupuri, nu va fi util. Înregistrezi valoarea de așteptare sau funcția de cost
pentru setul de parametri theta folosiți în starea ta și apoi actualizezi parametrii în timp. Poți folosi
valorile de așteptare sau valorile funcției de cost estimate pentru a aproxima un gradient al funcției de cost în
subspațiul stărilor eșantionate de ansatz-ul tău.
Există atât optimizatori clasici bazați pe gradient, cât și fără gradient. Ambii suferă de potențiale probleme de antrenare, cum ar fi
minime locale multiple și regiuni mari ale spațiului de parametri cu gradient aproape zero, numite platouri sterpe.
Deci va rezolva VQE toate problemele tale cele mai dificile? Nu. Dar să fie mai bun la toate calculele nu a fost niciodată scopul. Am
schimbat ceea ce determină costul computațional. Uită-te la ce am tranzacționat. Am trecut de la un proces
a cărui complexitate depinde doar de dimensiunea matricei la unul care depinde de precizia necesară și de numărul de
operatori Pauli care nu comutează și care alcătuiesc matricea. Ultima parte nu are analog în calculul clasic.
Pe baza acestor noi dependențe, pentru matrice rare sau matrice cu puțini șiruri Pauli care nu comutează, acest
proces poate fi util. Acesta este cazul sistemelor de spinuri cu interacțiuni. De exemplu, pentru matrice dense, s-ar putea să fie
mai puțin util. Știm, de exemplu, că sistemele chimice au adesea Hamiltonieni cu sute, mii, chiar și
milioane de șiruri Pauli. Au fost realizate lucrări interesante pentru a reduce acest număr de termeni, dar
sistemele chimice s-ar putea potrivi mai bine cu unii dintre ceilalți algoritmi pe care îi vom discuta în acest curs.
Utilizarea eficientă a VQE necesită, de asemenea, să cunoaștem atributele stării noastre țintă și să putem selecta o stare inițială fizic
motivată, precum și un ansatz bun cu relativ puțini parametri variaționali. Aceasta poate fi
destul de dificil. VQE demonstrează cum punctele forte ale calculatoarelor clasice și cuantice pot fi combinate
fără a adăuga metode mai recente. VQE nu ne ajută să rezolvăm probleme care nu pot fi tratate de calculatoarele clasice, dar
continuă să joace un rol în dezvoltarea algoritmilor. Și VQE ne învață, de asemenea, că transferarea unui pas de la calculatoarele clasice
la cele cuantice nu este nici mai bun, nici mai rău pentru toate scopurile. Mai degrabă,
schimbă factorii care determină eficiența algoritmului tău. Aceasta este o lecție generală importantă în calculul hibrid
cuantic-clasic.